what's up doc what do voldemort wonder
woman bugs bunny and rick and morty all
have in common
they all show up in space jam a new
legacy
space jam a new legacy is full of plenty
of different
references and cameos related to the
warner brothers library
from the studio's classic library and
even some of their newer titles
this film has it all so let's jump into
the server verse
and take a look at all the different
references space jam a new legacy has to
offer let's get some butts in dc
the audience watching the big toon squad
vs the goon squad game
is full of quite the celebrity audience
one of the audience members is lord
voldemort himself
likely cheering on that dreaded goon
squad hogwarts students and quidditch
players can also be seen watching from
the sidelines
making this one enchanting audience
hopefully
voldemort doesn't have the elder wand
this time only i
can live forever
space jam a new legacy takes a page from
disney's notebook with this little
reference
the number on marvin the martian ship
the uss martin
reads a113 this is actually the name of
a room number at cal arts where many of
the top animators in hollywood get their
start
this number typically has appeared in
various disney and pixar films
which makes its inclusion here all the
more interesting
just don't expect any pizza planet
trucks or luxo balls
you're kidding right the warner brothers
studio lot and offices
feature posters for many recent and
popular warner bros titles
these include scoob teen titans go to
the movies in the heights
the suicide squad aquaman joker
tom and jerry the big bang theory birds
of prey
mad max fury road and the matrix
revolutions
warner brothers sure seems to love
showing off their library
that's the power of warner 3000
as the villainous aig rhythm orders his
adorable sidekick pete to send lebron to
the rejects
a number of famous warner brothers
locations appear on the meter before
ultimately settling on toon world among
the locations that show up
are hogwarts from harry potter orbit
city from the jetsons
the mascara from wonder woman gotham
city from batman
emerald city from the wizard of oz
bedrock from the flintstones
and thundera from the thundercats so
many places
so little time i guess he fell for it as
lebron falls through the server-verse
he passes by several planets related to
various warner brothers titles
these include game of thrones harry
potter the wizard of oz
the matrix casablanca the maltese falcon
and the dc universe who knows what other
planets this server verse has to offer
the possibilities are almost endless
look at where you are
this is the greatest view in the entire
server verse foghorn leghorn makes his
grand entrance in the film
dressed as a familiar character from the
hit hbo series
game of thrones we see the loudmouthed
rooster dressed as mother of dragons
daenerys targaryen while riding drogon
out of the westeros planet shouting the
show's well-known quote
winter is coming some of warner brothers
most nefarious villains can be seen in
the audience
these include the white walkers from
game of thrones as well as the droogs
from a clockwork orange
maybe they are not the most fitting
characters to have in a looney tunes
movie
is that harry potter world as bugs and
lebron fly past the harry potter planet
lebron learns that his hogwarts house is
hufflepuff which he seems very excited
about
hufflepuff i know it nerd alert
despite this james had previously
appeared as a gryffindor earlier in the
film make up your mind space jam
lebron's son dom better look out for
this member of the crowd
the terrifying pennywise the dancing
clown from the it films
can be seen in the audience hopefully
he's too
into the game to realize that there's
kids in the audience as well
one of the film's biggest surprise
appearances are rick sanchez and morty
smith from the smash hit adult swim
series rick and morty
the grandfather and grandson appeared
dropping off the tasmanian devil to the
tuned ship
claiming that they are done running
tests of the rambunctious character
morty says that he saw things that'll
never leave his mind
he's your problem now dum-dum judging
from all the crazy misadventures they've
gone through
that must have been something the duo
are definitely
toned down in their appearances here but
it doesn't make their cameo
any less exciting that is awesome
a new legacy also makes references to
films outside the warner brothers
library
such as back to the future after a team
member of the goon squad scores some
points in the game
the famed delorean appears on the
jumbotron to reveal a graphic
resembling the license plate from the
classic film series
bill murray shows up in the film's end
credits in a social media post playing
golf with bugs bunny
this is an obvious callback to murray's
iconic role in the first film where he
played an exaggerated version of himself
okay little fella you my friend are you
my enemy
the portly aliens known as the nerdlucks
from the original 1996 space jam
make two brief appearances in their
original forms as spectators
rooting for the goon squad hopefully
they don't try to become the monstars
again
time to play a little basketball in the
film's opening flashback scene featuring
a pre-teen lebron
the game boy game that he happens to be
playing before getting on court
is the bugs bunny crazy castle this is
actually
one of the very first looney tune video
games ever made
while lebron has pitched the warner 3000
several busts of popular warner brothers
characters can be seen in the conference
room
these include bust of gizmo from
gremlins batman
the cowardly lion from the wizard of oz
dot warner from
animaniacs and marvin the martian which
can be found sitting behind lebron
dom malik and the studio execs likely
foreshadowing what's going to happen
next
several popular characters from the dc
animated series
show up at the metropolis train station
as well as
on board the runaway train commissioner
gordon and jimmy olsen can be seen at
the station
standing beside clark kent while harleen
quinzel
alfred pennyworth and lois lane are
panicking on board the train
the ever popular bugs bunny internet
meme
big chungus gets a quick shout out as
lebron first meets bugs
the joke actually stems from the early
looney tunes short wabbit twubble
during a scene where bugs bunny is
mocking his rival elmer fudd
[Music]
but it later took on a life of its own
as the infamous meme
welcome to my shop let me cut your mop
let me shave your crap
the barbershop scene in toon world that
lebron and bugs talk inside is an
obvious callback to one of the most
beloved bugs bunny shorts of all time
the rabbit of saville a framed photo of
bugs from the short
can even be seen hanging on the wall
this also serves as a reference to
lebron's hbo series
the shop which is a talk show set inside
a barber shop
maybe bugs bunny will appear in a future
episode
the famous dc super heroine appears in
this scene where lola must compete in an
obstacle course to become a true
amazonian of the maschira on top of that
the amazonian princess is voiced by none
other than rosario dawson who previously
voiced the character in other animated
movies
such as justice league dark apocalypse
war
the death and return of superman and
wonder woman bloodlines
you are now an amazon among the crowd of
warner brothers characters making their
way to the basketball court
migo michi and guangi from the animated
movie small foot can be seen running
towards the game
funnily enough both the characters of
michi and guangi were
actually voiced by a new legacy stars
zendaya and lebron james
i see i say how in the world did he get
all these spectators here
as lebron james falls into toon world
the impact his body leaves
is shaped like the iconic nike logo
after all
the movie has to promote lebron's
favorite shoe company somehow
especially since the first movie was
inspired by a nike commercial
before lebron takes on the goon squad a
shot reveals names of lebron's film
family on his shoes
a reference to one of lebron's most
famous pre-game rituals
of writing the names of his family on
his shoes
i masterminded this entire operation it
was him
it was definitely the pig some of the
justice league members from the early
2000s animated series justice league
unlimited
make an appearance as lebron and bugs
confront daffy
after creating quite the ruckus in the
midst of an animated metropolis
aquaman batgirl jon stewart as green
lantern the flash and of course superman
all show up together to confront daffy
for his destructive shenanigans
involving a runaway train and an
orphanage
folks a reference to the popular warner
brothers franchise austin powers
is made in the form of elmer fudd being
injected into a scene
from the second austin powers movie the
spy who shagged me
elmer fudd is shown dressed up as fan
favorite mini-me
while sylvester is standing in place for
dr evil's trusty cat
mr biglesworth makes you wonder who's
the stand-in for dr
evil sharks with friggin laser beams
among the audience the mystery inc gang
can be seen looking very similar to how
they appeared in their 2020 animated
film
scoob also from scoob is the superhero
blue falcon
who's seated not too far away from his
aliens from the film wow what was that
for
making sure this isn't a dream the
mischievous gremlins can also be seen
running towards the court and even takes
center stage for a brief moment
all three of the gremlins are wearing or
are equipped with something related to
the first gremlins movie
a santa hat a chainsaw and 3d glasses
hopefully this means we could be getting
a gremlins 3 announcement
sometime soon that's all folks
from looney tunes callbacks to cameo
appearances
and even teases for the future space jam
a new legacy definitely gave the
audience plenty of hidden goodies to
search for while watching the movie
it'd definitely be interesting to see
where the team can go from here
if they decide to make a space jam 3. do
you have a favorite hidden reference in
space jam a new legacy